there's something to be said about small
moments in anime that make a big
impression one piece is littered with
such moments they serve as catalysts for
plot progression and character
development they might even provide some
foreshadowing of the important events to
come sometimes they're integral to the
overall story or the arc in which they
occur and sometimes they're a juicy
accompaniment that might not be central
to the story but that definitely make it
better almost always they depict courage
heroism and attitude qualities we look
for in all of our favorite anime
characters naturally they're all badass
moments on that note here are the top 10
badass moments in one piece there are
major plot revelations ahead here so a
spoiler alert is now in full effect so
without further ado let's get started
at number 10 we have the moment when
zorro cuts pica in half the
shape-shifting enemy that can turn an
entire country into a part of his body
gives the straw hat immeasurable trouble
in the dressrosa arc they might laugh at
his squeaky voice but they know better
than to make light of one of the top
three officers of the don quixote family
so to see zorro who spent a lot of his
time in dressrosa wandering off and
getting lost cut the stone monster in
half is immensely satisfying he then
proceeds to slice and dice pika forcing
him to reveal himself in his true form
pika's defeat is proof of zorro's
growing strength and skill it takes him
that much closer to his goal of becoming
the world's greatest swordsman his
belief that there's nothing he can't cut
makes this one of those moments you
can't help but cheer loudly force
[Music]
next up is a hockey fight luffy knocking
out 50 000 fish men in the fishman
island arc when hody jones boasts that
luffy and his crew number just 10
whereas he has a hundred thousand men at
his disposal even some of the straw hats
are overwhelmed by the threat luffy
reduces that threat by half in an
instant talk about evening deontay it's
a proud moment for the straw hats who
realize their captain has mastered
conqueror's haki for fans it's the
payoff we get to see after the two years
luffy spent training with rayleigh what
also contributes to making this moment
special is the fact that one piece uses
its haki sparingly unlike a lot of other
anime that overexposed their power-ups
haki's a rare commodity in one piece
mastered by a chosen few and used only
in big moments for luffy the incident at
fishman island is one of his early uses
of haki after the time skip but remains
an unforgettable memory
[Music]
foreign
it's another one-man show at number
eight with law cutting punk hazard in
half for all of his lectures to luffy
about the virtues of lying low and
fighting cautiously the captain of the
heart pirates is known to make some big
and bold moves every now and then
challenging doflamingo to a fight for
purely personal reasons is one plotting
the fall of kaido is another as for his
flashiest moment in battle it's without
a doubt his dismantling of virgo and the
island of punk hazard showing that he's
one of the most imaginative devil fruit
powers around law needs just one swing
of his blade to cut virgo in half
despite the latter's body being entirely
armored in haki in the process the
facility which produces the main
ingredient for doffy's fake devil fruits
and the mountain it's built on also get
carved beyond repair it's a moment where
you can't help but be impressed by the
surgeon of death
[Music]
at number 7 we have a special moment
from the marineford arc which is crowded
with special moments
after taking the aerial route into the
fortress-like marine headquarters luffy
gets airborne once again this time using
a pillar of water and a ship's mask to
propel himself towards the execution
platform and ace but standing in his way
are the three admirals talking purely
from the visual standpoint the image of
the young upstart standing up to the
navy's three strongest warriors and
directly challenging their authority
makes for a great poster however luffy
recklessly facing off against aokiji
kizaru and ikainu is important not only
for the visuals and the events taking
place it seems in all likelihood to be a
foreshadowing of the final confrontation
between the man who will be the pirate
king and the authorities standing in his
way we can't wait to see what happens
when the anime eventually winds down to
such a finale
[Music]
up next is a similar scene from the
ennis lobby arc this time with the straw
hat challenging not the navy but the
world government and this time too the
reason is personal robin's being
captured by the cp9 the world
government's top secret group of
assassins luffy and gang break into
enemies lobby the notoriously fortified
judicial island that serves as the
organization's headquarters rarely do we
see the straw hats stand as a single
team in one frame most of the time
they're off doing their own thing but
here seeing them all together on the
roof of the courthouse and standing
shoulder to shoulder as they challenge
the cp-9 and its leaders spandem it's
impossible not to feel a rush of
excitement the detestable spandem points
to the futility of their challenge
bragging that the small crew's no match
for the government's might in response
luffy has sergey king shoot a flaming
arrow at the government flag it's a
declaration of war that shows luffy has
no problem picking a fight with someone
bigger and stronger than him
[Music]
the straw hats walk to arlong park to
challenge arlong takes the 5th spot this
was at a time when the crew had only 4
members and it comes right after that
unforgettable scene where the usually
ballsy nami breaks down in tears and
asks luffy to help her save her village
from the tyranny of the arlon pirates
handing his hat to his future navigator
for safe keeping luffy gathers his
troops which comprises of zorro sanji
and usof and the four march to arlong
park it's an iconic moment reminiscent
of many a memorable walking scene from
the movies when sidekicks johnny and
yosaku tell the villagers these four men
are worth betting their lives on you
might find yourselves nodding in
agreement again in terms of imagery this
moment makes the same impact as the
previously discussed challenge to the
world government to end its lobby and
the straw hats farewell to vivi in the
alabaster arc it just goes to show that
putting the straw hats together in one
frame is a thing of magic i think for a
lot of fans this was a turning point in
the series where they went from liking
the series to loving it and i can see
exactly why
[Music]
the marine foot arc is the one arc in
one piece that's guaranteed to make the
viewer an emotional wreck thanks to its
numerous acts of courage betrayals and
god awful tragedy it also has one of the
most powerful conclusions as shanks
appears during the final assault and
puts an end to what's now just senseless
fighting due to this intervention luffy
gets away safely akainu is stopped
thousands of lives are saved and the
fallen get the dignity they deserve in
death it's a moment that reveals the
true strength of this yonko who's
remained a mystery to us all these years
despite being a central figure in
luffy's life that fleet admiral sengoku
is willing to listen to him an adversary
and a pirate raises our expectations for
what shanks is capable of in the future
this is also one of the few times we see
shanks as the powerful pirate that he is
with his ship and crew by his side cameo
appearances don't get any more powerful
than this
[Music]
[Music]
and marineford is anime legend by now
his death's even more epic but there's a
moment in between that really says a lot
about the kind of man he is there's no
honor in ganging up on an opponent even
one as fearsome as the towering
whitebeard yet the marines singled him
out throwing everything they've got at
him it's a good strategy but hardly
heroic what's heroic is whitebeard's
response as he stops his crew from
rushing to his aid i am whitebeard he
roars even with his body bearing
hundreds of battle wounds and cannonball
smoke rising from his face with just
these words he makes the marines who
pride themselves as upholders of justice
look dirty and dishonorable and those
aren't empty words whitebeard goes on to
show the marines just who they're
messing with we can't help but be proud
[Music]
as you might already know in one piece
the celestial dragons aren't just
nobility but practically godlike even
the carefree luffy understands that
they're not to be trifled with no matter
what atrocities they commit well he gets
it in theory at least anyway but when
the idiotic saint charlotte shoots hachi
at the slave auction and luffy gets that
glint in his eye you know it's not going
to end well for the high-handed noble
heart cheese entreaties to luffy to let
the matter slide even going to the
extent of saying he deserves to be shot
makes no difference to luffy who marches
up to charlos and socks him in the face
one punch and charlos is out for the
count apparently that fishbowl-like
headgear the celestial dragons wear
isn't exactly much protection what luffy
does is audacious even for someone who's
in the habit of doing the exact opposite
of what he's told but seeing a bully get
what he deserves is immensely satisfying
and that brings us to number one and
it's zorro's finest hour yet in the
service of his captain
[Music]
having realized that luffy and the rest
of the crew are too exhausted from their
battle with gekko maurya and his zombie
army to have any real chance of survival
against bartholomew kumar zoro makes the
ultimate sacrifice unknown to them the
proud swordsman gets down on his knees
and asks the warlord to spare luffy and
the others offering himself up for
punishment on their behalf due to the
nature of kuma's powers that means
taking all of luffy's pain and fatigue
into his own body i'll show you hell
kuma promises reminding zorro that he
might not survive the ordeal zorro does
survive it somehow and when sanji later
finds him covered in blood but still
standing he asks what happened
nothing happened a typical answer from a
man of few words and yet it's so telling
it's just one of the many things that
make this strong and loyal pirate such a
badass the fact that luffy doesn't know
about this little incident to this day
makes this moment even more special
[Music]
so there you have it the top 10 badass
moments in one piece which one do you
think was the most badass write to me in
the comments section below and let me
know your thoughts if you enjoyed the
video press the like button you can also
subscribe to vinitube for more anime and
one piece content there's plenty here
that might catch your otaku eye be sure
to tune in for my next video and until
then goodbye and stay safe
[Music]
you